hello everyone a very warm greeting to
one and all my name is sri gavri krishna
kumar and i would like to welcome you
all for today's webinar on omixlogic
metagenomics data analysis program so
before we dive in what is this program
all about
we know that advancements in
metagenomics research has led to new
ideas regarding the diagnosis and
management of human diseases but did you
know that although the metagenomic
studies continue to increase in their
number sequence volume and complexity
there still remains a lot of
metagenomics data that are yet to be
explored
that is why we have in we are
introducing a program to introduce
students researchers and clinicians to
the field of metagenomics this program
will explore how different types of
analysis can be used to understand the
microbial world we will cover several
bioinformatics approaches to compare
microbial composition in different
conditions learn about the sequencing of
viral samples and discuss how microbes
evade the immune response of the host as
well as the treatment
the applications of metagenomics will be
covered in skin and acne food
sensitivity autoimmune diseases cancer
antibiotic treatment drug resistant and
even in the field of ecology
we are also glad to announce the
upcoming hackathon on microbiome in
health and wellness from november 1st to
november 28 2022.
this is an initiative to provide
students with a platform to showcase
their innovative mindset of problem
solving here each student will have the
opportunity to develop a mini project
around the hackathon topic form a team
with at least two other students and
compete against each other for
mentorship support from established
companies and long-term interest from
the business community the applications
of the hackathon are in the fields of
obesity and precision nutrition
innovation and beauty products and
finally pregnancy so i would like to
urge all the participants to be a part
of this hackathon and make the most out
of such a wonderful opportunity if you
wish to know more about this event
please click on the link that will be
provided to you by one of our team
members in the chat box
so before we begin with today's webinar
let me also take a brief moment to
introduce you to the team behind the
program
we are a us-based bioinformatics company
who is working with multiple academic
and commercial collaborators to develop
easy to use analytical tools and our
mission is to make bioinformatics more
accessible
the omics logic training has been
completed by over 24 000 participants
from 187 countries in over 300 workshops
and due to this fast growth our team is
working with local and regional
coordinators that are helping refine
local program logistics and adapting
them to the needs of students and
researchers around the world and this
training has been completed by
participants in six different
specialization tracts that include
oncology infectious diseases precision
medicine neuroscience data science for
biomedical data and comprehensive
training on women's data analysis
so how do omics logic resources help
advance bioinformatics teaching
omix logic is a portal for practical and
theoretical learning of bioinformatics
it takes a combination of training
modules data analysis tools curated
project data sets and interactive
sessions with mentors to give the
student a clear path up the bloom's
taxonomy permit no matter what the
user's initial experience with
bioinfomatics is omixlogic is a useful
tool for gaining a baseline knowledge of
the theory behind bioinformatics
analysis of large data sets and
introduction to basic coding languages
like r and python or even beginning a
data analysis project
this program comes with an access to the
omen strategy courses which includes
precision medicine
multi-omics including genomics
transatomics metagenomics epigenomics
data science that includes
bioinformatics using r and python
and example projects of different fields
which you could learn from and replicate
for your research work
users will be given directions to access
the t bioinfo platform for
bioinformatics processing and analysis
of data the platform includes demo
pipelines as well as data management and
analysis cloud infrastructure to run
bioinformatics pipelines different
stages of analysis are performed in
different sections on this multi-omics
platform
so first of all let's begin by signing
up on the portal
but before we begin here are some of the
things that you need to keep in mind for
a completed profile that is a completed
profile will have full name with
appropriate capitalization linked to
your social media handles this could be
your facebook linkedin instagram or
kyrie or even twitter a brief buyer
bought yourself that will consist of
your educational background and research
interest
the mentors can view your progress under
the activity tab the courses you are
currently completing will appear under
the courses tab finally after the
completion of your course the
certificates will appear under the
certificate site so with that let us
begin by signing up on the portal i'll
be sharing the link in the chat box
please click on the link and i'll walk
you through the process behind signing
up on the protein
so here is the link
so for users who do not have an existing
account on the portal please click on
the option that says create an account
option
here you will be asked to enter your
name email id and a password you also
have the option to sign up using any of
your social media accounts this could be
a google facebook apple account github
account or even twitter with that i'll
pause for a couple of minutes for the
participants to sign up once you have
signed up please put a yes in the chat
box and if you're facing any technical
issues for signing up on the portal you
can share that in the chat as well and
our team will be happy to help you
so i'm waiting for the responses once
you have signed up please put a yes in
the chat box
all right mancy has signed up sparsh has
signed up
all right i'm waiting for rest of the 50
plus participants
have you guys signed up
all right
all right great so
so since i already have an account on
the portal i'm going to click on the
login now option and
directly sign in
once you sign in
you're able to view the various courses
and example projects under the courses
tab so please feel free to browse
through the list at your own pace
after the
webinar gets over so since most of you
are interested in metagenomics so i'm
just going to
view
the courses and example projects that
are there on this topic so i could see
that there are example projects on role
of high fat diet obesity effective
dietary fiber intake on microbiome
effect of antibiotics and red syndrome
and if i wish to gain my concepts first
then i could also enroll for the course
now the most important step that i
discussed previously was setting up the
profile
so
for that click on the tab that says
welcome pack with your email address so
how do you edit the features that i
mentioned before click on the icon that
says
profile and here you will be able to
edit each of the features such as
uploading your profile image your bio
your name linking to your social media
accounts and in my case i've linked my
linkedin and my op id now under the
activity tab the mentor and the
community manager will be able to track
your progress and once you start taking
any courses it will appear on the
courses tab and if you are enrolling for
any of the and if you have uploaded
uploaded any projects it will upload
under the projects tab and if you're
enrolling for any of the programs such
as metagenomics it will appear under the
programs tab so once you complete any of
the courses
the certificates will appear under the
courses tab
all right so if you have any queries so
far please put them in the chat box and
we'll i'll be able to guide you
if the participants have no further
queries i would like to pass on the
stage to dr raghvan lakshmi narayan he
is the bioinformatics mentor and
research consultant at pine biotech he
will be taking today's webinar so over
to you sir
thank you thank you very much regarding
let me find ways to share my stream
so you are
if you have any questions about signing
up and if you have any questions about
the
accounts in general this is the time to
put it in the chat box and we are
going to be
monitoring the chat box so you can use
the chat box to interact with me
section
yes sir it's please confront
my screen and i'm audible to you
yes sir you're ordered
thank you very much
this
meta genomics is
as we know is a way to study
microorganisms in their natural
environment
by exploring the species of richness and
by investigating the functional roles of
these microbial communities and what
they play
and
the role that they play in many areas
that related to human health and human
disease
in our general well-being
so in this webinar you will learn about
the upcoming omics logics meta dynamics
program and these programs
as we know and as we have been
presenting
are designed to be rewarding to students
researchers faculties and citizen
scientists and etc etc many people who
are generally interested in
understanding omics analysis to several
different homage data profiles
the program in general will cover main
aspects of metagenomic sequencing the
analysis of
sexiness rrna sequencing data and the
other aspects of
microbiology research using
bioinformatics and downstream analysis
of metagenomic sequencing outputs using
r and python and using code free
platform
etc using the turbo bioinfo
um
you will be
familiar
in metagenomics
data analysis and metagenomic sequencing
generally analysis in general and you
will be able to conduct independent
projects and independent analysis and
you will be
equipped to handle data from publicly
available
and somebody new
yes uh thank you
am i audible still
yes sir you're honorable
i think my screenshot gone
okay wait a second screenshot is
creating some problems
okay i think i should be
uh you should be able to see my screen
yes it's visible that's perfect so i was
talking to you about uh
how generally this program will
accumulate eq participants like you to
be able to conduct independent projects
using metagenomic sequence analysis data
and you will also be able to handle and
find data from publicly available
resources and public domain and you can
also
learn from high impact biomedical
publications on the microbiome the kind
of analysis that they perform and what
are they actually referring to when they
are talking about the diversity and that
that also leads to dysbiosis and
symbiosis of microbial population in
relationship to the phenotypical
characteristics of the sample or under
different biological conditions with
which the samples are actually recorded
or referred
so as in all of our comics logic
training program we will use online
sessions we will use asynchronous
sessions we will use uh self-guided
study materials and we will use several
different example projects that
that will help you get a effective
understanding and good experience of
understanding the
concepts
related to the metagenomics sequence
analysis and metagenomics data analysis
so let's
dive into this session with the focus on
metagenomics focusing mostly on the
bioinformatics part related to the
analysis of the sequencing data so
before we begin let's see
and how are the different areas with
which we can relate the meta genomics
data and meta genomics information too
and ask important questions about these
microbial communities and
and
also review a couple of studies that are
used to characterize microbiota from
different resource sources
so the connection between disease and
microorganisms has been established in
the 1800s and we already know that
towards the end of the 19th century we
have several established laboratory
methods for growing
microorganisms in lab culture right and
these
developed methods of growing these
organisms in laboratories
with straining and other methods and
helps us understand their
characteristics and help us understand
their relationship to our
diseases and
pathogenicity in general
right and these studies in the earlier
stages of understanding the
microorganisms uh helps us are they
actually provided us important
information about these bacteria or
these microbes and their function in
isolation but however it was soon
apparent and we
already found out that
most of these microbial organisms live
in a complex community today we know
that these microorganisms or we call
them as microbiota that make up the
human microbiology are not just
unicellular organisms living alongside
each other but instead they form highly
regulated highly structural and highly
functionally organized communities that
are
skin attached to several different
organs and
they collaborate with the organs and
they contribute to the ecological and
they contribute to the stability and
well-being of the tissues and of the
organism that they are found part of
so uh to give an estimate the human
microbiota biotite is estimated to be
around 10 to the power 13 or 14 of
microbial cells and they roughly
translate into one is to one ratio of
microbial cells to human cells
ratio number
and these microbes they form distinct
communities and they are interconnected
to maintain their community the
stability of these communities in their
own environment is a fascinating study
and the researchers that are all that
helped us understand these stabilities
and the effort that these microbes
put in to maintain these stabilities are
fascinating and they give us
several insights into how these stable
environment
relate to our well-being and our
reaction to different disease states and
different pathogenicity
and we already know that and we already
also see the bacteria can communicate
with each other by producing detecting
and responding to several small
diffusible signal molecules
the fencing of these signal molecules
are also involved in the virulence and
the pathogenic potential of the bacteria
and is therefore an important factor in
understanding and controlling
bacterial infection in general
so inside and alongside each of these
community there is a balance of bacteria
fungi and viruses that control species
abundance and activity so in each of
these environment each one of these
microorganisms carry important
functional properties
in genes that contain genomic
information right we can study the
genomic
data of these microorganisms to
understand the properties of the genes
and to understand the functional
importance of these microorganisms in
their environment
these properties and the genomic
information about these microorganisms
have been of a growing interest to the
scientific community and it has already
resulted in over eighty thousand
publications in total or and it's still
growing
and the majority of these studies have
actually focused on intestinal
microbiome and several other areas of
microbial
population and studies are also coming
into uh
coming into their research or coming
into the height
so however since 1990s microbiome
studies are actually significantly
advanced to through several major
initiatives like the metagenomics of
human intestinal tract and human
microbiome project and huge studies
several such studies have made possible
through the advances of
advances in meta-genomic sequencing in
general and these sequencing which are
as a result of which came as a result of
development in high throughput
sequencing efforts or next generation
sequencing effort have actually made it
possible that there is a there is an
ever increasing
amount or ever increasing availability
of the data
that can uh easily pour into several of
the derived data that several of the
derived projects and research that
that are fueled by the existence of such
biological data
so as a result of these studies skin
lung gut and even brain microbiota are
starting are starting to be getting
characterized and their relationship
with our well-being and the general
their involvement in um in uh
in maintaining balance between um
symbiosis general biosis of our
microbial community are constantly being
explored and related
so today we know that the endogenous
human microbial communities contributes
to critical metabolic critical
physiological and immunological
functions and these are all functions
that include
differentiation and maturations of the
immune system and sometimes they include
food digestion and nutrition
elements and they also include metabolic
regulation and control of the fat
storage or energy storage and they are
also involved in processing and
detoxification of environmental
chemicals and we also know from acne and
other related studies they are involved
in maintaining skin and the mucosa
barrier function
and
more
relations or more uh
key connections are establishing or
getting established in the development
and regulation of the immune system
inflammatory and anti-inflammatory
substances are also getting actively
studied on so prevention and invasion of
innovation
of disease promoting microorganisms and
and the general colonization resistance
and general resistance of
advantages microbes to these
disease-promoting microorganisms are
also being
actively explored
so the term metagenomics covers all of
these studies and refers to both the
research technique and also the research
field so the field can be defined as the
genomic analysis of the microbial dna
from these environmental communities
that we discussed on and
the tools that used to study these
analysis
enable us to understand or enable us to
make a population analysis of previously
unknown microbes or previously
unculturable or uncharacterized microbes
of bacteria in general
this is very very important
in the current scenario because only
around one to two percentage of the
bacteria can be cultured and grown and
studied in the laboratory and the
ability to identify these microbes
without their priory knowledge of what
the sample contains is actually opening
new doors into the research areas like
ecology like biology microbiology
environmental science and biomedical
research etc etc
the sequencing based examination of the
metagenome has become an extremely
powerful tool for understanding their
diversity and their effects in several
of these
research areas that i just listed on and
has become very useful tool in
generating novel hypothesis that relates
this
metagenome to several of these research
areas
so this sequencing can actually apply to
any culture free environmental
population as well as it can be applied
to
any general detailed extraction of uh
microorganisms
that can be characterized with or
without culturing in labs and often
often uh times
in order to gain a complete
understanding of these
selected few microorganisms these
techniques are combined first
uh a detailed or an exploratory
metagenomics approach has been applied
to some to culture-free sample and then
from these selected few microorganisms
are actually grown in the laboratory
culture to explore and to verify the
hypothesis that we generate from the
meta genomic sequencing or this culture
free sequencing techniques
so many of these questions are being
answered as i mentioned using the
using the tools such as using the very
important tool that is next generation
sequencing which focuses on either
sequencing the whole genome or the whole
or it can focus on
sequencing selected g
like 16 srna or 18s rrna of the microbes
or sometimes
selected portions of these genes
of the microbes right and each and in ah
and in performing uh these different
sequencing methods we will focus or we
are going to focus on answering or
addressing several important several
different key questions and uh that will
help us
generate hypotheses related to the data
related to the biological
condition of the samples that we have
so in general when we look or when we
discuss about these different
technologies and these different methods
that are used to characterize meta
genomics and microbial population
we have
shotgun metagenomics and we have a 16s
metagenomics or amplifon sequencing
methods while the shotgun metagenomics
or transcriptomics meta transcriptomics
will
focus on understanding all of the genes
or the whole genome of the microbes and
this can help us in analyzing for
example
the general assembly with the help of
the general genome assembly of these
several different microbes we can get
key insights into their functional
contribution in maintaining the um
maintaining the balance and in helping
us with the
with the processing of the metabolites
we can also
prediction of the genes across
to be a key uh factor or key player in
maintaining these meta and maintaining
this and metabolome on their
processing levels
so while uh shotgun meta genomics and
transcriptomics will address at the
functional level of the microbial
population in addition to sometimes
in addition to uh giving us an estimate
of these microbial population
more um
what to say uh
more reliable methods in in estimating
the abundance level of these several
these
different astronomical level can be
performed using 16s amplicon
metagenomics right this 16
is is a technique that is widely used to
study
microbiome directly in its environment
and this will focus on either as i
already mentioned 16 sr18s ribosomal rna
that has to be
amplified using pcr amplification method
before getting quantified and matched
onto the database of uh known fixiness
rrna sequences
so these sequences
uh contain hypervariable regions and
variable regions that provide species
specific signature sequences that are
extremely useful and are used to
identify bacteria and their taxonomic
ranks
how are these how are they generally
performed
so they are actually in addition to
sequencing
these pcr amplified uh reads or pcr
amplified
shared products of these gs16s rrna gene
uh we
pool them or we generally
cluster them
in group of closely related individuals
as defined by their taxonomic uh
identity or taxonomic uh or sequential
identity or sequential similarity
similarities right these consensus
sequences are actually defined as
operational taxonomical taxonomic units
and their abundance uh is actually
characterized and quantified for
different samples
yes ram kumar otus is are no longer in
use as we have asbs because asvs can be
can be a general term that can take
anywhere between 95 percentage of the
sequence identity to 99 percentage otus
are restricted in than in the amount of
identity that are used to define
how two sequences are related to each
other that is why okay
it's not the case that it is not
generally in use it is still in use but
in order to have a very generic
application of the sequential identity
and
their relationship to identifying key
taxonomic
ranks
we are referring to asms okay
all right so they can be classified or
they can be clustered using general
clustering approaches that will
cluster these
reads based on the
percentage of identity percentage
identity level that we are defining
while defining the amount of uh while
defining the
taxonomic units that we want to
characterize so we were discussing that
these taxonomic units are actually
a
taxonomic
organization in terms of
kingdom phylum class
genus etc etc so these these otus are
the one
that are identified as
specific species of genus or phyla of
bacteria and they are the one that are
that will get characterized or that that
are that will get quantified uh along uh
among different samples that we have
so once this quantification is performed
as i mentioned they are identified to be
part of these specific ranks
these specific ranks using special using
spec
taxonomic information for domains of
bacteria archaea and eukarya and
etcetera etcetera right it is primarily
based on the phytogenesis of the
subunits of rna and
thank you ramakumar and yeah
subunits of the 16s or
and
their relationship to the taxonomic
ranks that we already discussed about so
in addition to this we also have by rome
which refers to one part of microbiome
that constitutes all of the organisms
are that contributes to uh all of the
viruses that might inhibit that might
inhabit us right
so characterizing the the biome of
mammalian
mammalian samples are our
samples and their relationship to
causing disease is also extremely
important because sometimes these
viruses can be carrier for several other
they are also implicated in being
carrier 2
oncology related uh issues and
yeah oncology uh
oncological implications and several
tumor progression are also being
implicated to these abundance levels of
specific viruses
so
we see that in the hierarchy of
biological classification this is what
we will be catching
microbial community that means
different tissues as a
studied organ is the gut but gut is not
the only place where these communities
live with and specific microbiomes
actually
coexist with us or with the host
and they are all vital for our health
and they are found in skin in
in
red parts and also sometimes
recent studies are
to do
as we already discussed
into the way these communities function
and how their composition right
generally their composition in terms of
or in the function of their abundance
level are linked to the host condition
that we are studying so what are the
host condition that we can relate this
to for example in the human microbiome
project we have several of the
parameters so several of the
data
that we can associate this adult
microbiome and their um
and their composition
they can be
uh
they can be linked to the bmi they can
be linked to their lifestyle they can be
linked to dietary habits they can be
linked to smoking and drinking habits
they can be linked to exercise frequency
and several of these characteristics can
be
can be explored
right and
while exploring this when we form
two subsets of these samples based on
based on the
lifestyle or based on the
health index or based on these
these characteristics we can actually
relate or we can actually identify a
balanced microbiota which is referred to
as biosis and
and symbiosis and also we can also
characterize
the level of unbalanced microbiota
which is referred to as dysbiosis in the
event of
microbial population that are found in
patients are found in people with
chronic diseases or people that are
related to disease conditions in
general right in addition to this we can
also have several uh types of
these microbiome that are characterized
for their ability to help us maintain a
good biosis or symbiosis right this can
be used in terms of
following
uh new probiotic
samples and
yeah
and
so we have by a while uh when we are
performing this analysis we can actually
identify and we can actually list
for example
bacteria types such as bacterial phyla
such as bacterial diabetes
proteobacteria and
their involvement in maintaining the
symbiosis
thermocute
foreign
so
these are all several several different
associations that we can perform so
basically in summary what we want to do
is we want to have a microbial
quantification for the samples under at
least two different conditions right one
condition could be ah from unhealthy
state of this organism and the other
condition could be healthy state or
control of that
this doesn't have to stop at exploring
the health issues of human this can
extend to for example um
for example the suitability of the soil
samples for plant growth this can uh
this can extend to uh for example
a soil
quantification characterization in
general right and and several
applications of this is actually done
and
yeah etcetera that can be studied
so we will take a look at couple of
these practical examples and in this
practical examples i want to show you
some of the i want to highlight some of
the important
key findings and how
we can perform some of the analysis
using omics logic
portal to arrive at this conclusion and
how we can leverage publicly available
resources to generate a hypothesis on
how that hypothesis can be tested using
code free environment in trying to
analyze the microbial or meta genomics
data and also using some code oriented
downstream analysis that are focusing on
understanding the diversity of this
microbial population
right
so if you have any questions until now
this is the time that you want to uh
ask and you can i'm monitoring the chat
as i mentioned please go ahead and ask
me the questions and before we jump into
the practical examples
okay
thank you sigur
so um
so we already spoke about human
microbial american microbeam project and
uh we we have uh for example
uh american gut project which can be uh
used to find patterns in the guts right
patterns in the microbial population
that can
be used to study
different ages in different population
or that can generally be used to
link to
where these
populations are microbes are actually
sourced from and that can also be linked
to several other comparison like
like the abundance level of specific uh
specific microbial population and
etcetera etcetera in general this is the
data that we have from this publicly
available resources so we can
it can we can
leverage the
gut sample and we can leverage several
samples and their
abundance levels of these microbes and
they can these abundance levels can be
related to as i already mentioned um for
those people under different clinical
conditions like those who exercise
regularly and those who exercise badly
so in addition to this we have several
of these clinical parameters and
clinical conditions to relate that to
and you're all free to check that
check and this
american gut
database and that is this my microbiome
dot info
website
so in addition to this we can also focus
on the
skin microbiome which is established
in this study which are identified
to play a key role in maintaining the
healthiness and maintaining the
symbiosis in
in the skin condition and also dysbiosis
in this skin microbiome and their
signaling is actually directly related
to
several
acute skin diseases like
eczema and other rashes etc etc so you
can also check this out these are all um
very important uh publications that you
want to explore in order to understand
the use and not understand the
applications of this microbiome and
metagenomics data analysis so
the next in focus would be
[Music]
the effect of these antibiotics in red
syndrome and for this i want to
extend the sharing of my screen to
exploring this project from omixlogic
platform and we will understand how
studying the microbiome dysbiosis in the
redstone will help us
generally relate
these dysfunctional abundance to one of
the rare neurological disorders that are
affecting the
affecting children
so let me reshare my screen
with my browser
okay uh just let me know if you can see
my screen
yes sir it's visible yes
thank you very much so uh
so this is this is an example project
that actually focuses on uh
understanding the microbial yeah thank
you very much right for the link and
those who have access to this project
can actually open up this project with
your
login credentials and uh explore it with
me or you can also do this later so um
we focus on uh the lessons that
generally starts
with a focus on
[Music]
relating the effectiveness of the drugs
against these different microbial
population and their effect of effect on
on disturbing the balance of this
microbial population in general and
these drugs for example are actually
non-antibiotic drugs and their effect on
microbiota
what are the key understanding of these
ones so in um
in a nutshell what this actually does is
uh we actually identify some of the key
bacterial population and uh and their
involvement in maintaining
symbiosis and
and how they are actually depleted in
terms of uh while while using several of
these uh
non-antibiotic prescription drugs that
we use and
you can go through this lesson to get to
the specifics but more than 70
percentage of the drugs will have one or
the other will affect one or the other
population of these
useful or
helpful uh microbial communities and
this actually lists out some of the
helpful microbial community that are
that are related to maintaining good
health like beauty rate produces like
propionate produces like
antenotypes and etc so we take this
information and then we go back to
another publication
that generally understands the or
generally focuses on
characterizing the abundance of
microbial community in in gut and relate
that to red syndrome a red syndrome is a
extremely rare neurological or a
neurodevelopmental disorder that
affects
mainly kids or children so
we want to understand whether do we have
any relationships or
whether we can
test the hypothesis does that
from the previous publication or from
the previous relationship that these
beneficial microbial community are the
ones that are among
the microbes that are mostly affected in
the
in the event of red syndrome samples
that we want to find out that's a
hypothesis that we are testing in this
specific
example project so next you can check
some of the
examples or some of the um
associated research and
thistles on
what was generally done in this
publication and how we are going to use
this data to study how to test our
hypothesis
and one of them is going to get this
load
one of them is going to be
using the processed data or the
tabulated data
and setting up a data to pipeline in the
tbio info server so this data to
pipeline will actually
give us lot of output that we can take
this output and use this
output either in in
in the visualization that we get from
the tbio info server and then the
interactive
environment that we get in the tbio info
server and understand or we can also use
kind analysis so
on top of this data to analysis and
packages everything into a time object
or kind uh compressed data type and this
kind compressed data type can be
downloaded and they can be straight away
visualized into kind visualizer that you
can access online
in
the kind database out in the prime
website so first let's uh
see how we can set up these data sets
and how we can set up this data analysis
and this lesson actually focuses on
where this data comes from and what do
we need to do to get these short read
sequencing
data and to
use these short read sequencing data to
uh
to arrive at the taxonomic table and
etcetera etcetera so that is what this
one focuses on first primarily
in this
in
in these steps to download data and once
you have obtained at this table we can
actually perform this uh downstream
analysis of this um using data to
pipeline and we can set up these
analysis in the
server also
and
this and our
part of this data or curated part of
portion of this data is included as a
demo pipeline in the server the bioinfo
server let this complete loading and it
can be accessed under this uh amplicon
16s are 18 sequencing in the
metagenomics section so if you have
login credentials to server uh tibor
info server irrespective of your
subscription pattern or subscription
model you can access all of the demo
pipelines and this demo pipeline can be
accessed by these using this drop down
[Music]
button or clicking option and in this we
can see
i think it's in the red syndrome is here
yeah that's information time but um i
will i will generally show you how to uh
set up a data to pipeline uh not for the
red syndrome but for the different
projects
so we start with the analysis part and
the input files are actually
already uploaded and we have you can
access them from here
and once you start we actually perform
some quality control
for our
files
and then we
count them or we use the
data to uh processes to
count to merge and to cluster these
otus that's what we will do and once
this has been done we can actually
remove um more than one otu uh cluster
dash or more than one type of other
plastered into one cluster that have
chimeras and we can then use these oto
sequences to
explore the silva database or any other
database to assign
tax
then we can use a
neighbor joining algorithm to develop
phylogenetics of these otus which is one
of the key
steps in understanding or in
exploring or characterizing the
diversity of these otus or these samples
then we can perform data visualization
then we can end the pipeline so once you
build this pipeline for the analysis and
in any method that you are kind to you
will get access to all the output files
that you can download and you can
visualize and we can explore and what to
explore and what to perform and what are
the analysis to focus what are the
results to be uh
identified and implicated can be
thoroughly
read and understood from the associated
resources that we are linking to during
each and every session of the program so
i want to show you some of the
visualization that we actually show
and this is abundance plot
that you will
often
see or often notice in microbial or meta
genomics related publication
i think we should yes exactly yeah and
we this is an interactive abundance part
we can quickly check uh which uh
tax of bacteria is this does this uh
specific section
and we see some uh difference in the
abundance level of these bacterial
identities for different samples that
can be related to their biological
condition or phenotypical
and this
specific plot which is not proportional
plot which is raw abundance plot and the
relative abundance relative proportional
abundance plot can be used to understand
the proportional abundance of several
different microbial population
or different samples
so this project also i think gives you
option to
guys to run the pipeline i think in the
yes it gives the same result same uh
discusses the same thing here
here is where you can actually uh
access the pipeline that we are
we actually set up for the uh lesson
that we focuses on focus on right it's
the same uh data to pipeline but for the
uh
it's not for the reds don't know it's
for different pipelines
so uh i wanted to
show you that this proportional plot
will help us ah
clear some of the hypothesis that we
generally
develop once seeing the non-proportional
or absolute uh abundance plot now if we
see this level of the bacterial
identities in these three samples they
are absolutely identical because it is
being scaled up or it has been
normalized across the different happens
that's what we wanted to show you so
these
interactive visualization will help
abundance level of our abundance level
of microbial community from our sample
and in order to perform more uh specific
analysis that we will also uh briefly
and
then we don't like r or python 2 do the
perform that analysis now i want to uh
again go to the red syndrome project and
show you that the next lesson actually
focuses on using kind for this analysis
and
uh you can again view some of the
uh
processes and setting up this pipeline
i'm not going to go over this uh one
more time for you so you can check that
in this lesson
and let's see if we can get to the
link for this pipeline
yes okay it's not here but that's okay
let's go to the server and that can be
accessed again as a demo pipeline under
the chime section of the metagenomics
part right in this
kind we see that the red syndrome
project is here
we can go and set up this analysis
quickly
so crime adds some more
steps to process and preprocess the data
and post process the data into time
objects
before applying data to pipeline into
that or data to analysis into that into
our data right
and it does it performs all the steps
that we do in the data tool
but it gives us some more options or
more options to
perform some quality visualization
once this is done
the details for these steps are all
included in the associated publications
uh not publication in the associated
resources
go
so when you sign up for this program you
will get access to
okay what happened here
can you see my screen it's a little bit
yes sir the screen is visible just it's
black
blacked out right yeah for some reasons
it is yeah for some reason
okay let me start over again
in order to access the
dashboard or
analyzing this data or changing the
key parameters of this data
during visualization process
so that you can perform this analysis
without
rerunning the pipeline or without any
without resorting to any code based
methods which we will also explore
option is available for kind
and
for most of the pipelines that you are
going to set up in the talbot bioinfo
server
so the processes involved in
selecting the next available or
choosing
uh one of the next available uh analysis
options that are highlighted when you
select the previous ones so since this
is a demo pipeline it's it's only
letting me select uh the path with which
we have set up the pipeline and in
reality when you select or when you opt
for these analysis methods when you
select one of these
options or algorithms then it's going to
give you all the or it's going to
highlight all possible route that you
can take so why should i say that you
can design your analysis
methods or sequences depending upon the
data depending upon the
hypothesis that you are actually testing
so this external dashboard will give you
options like
edited load
options like changing the taxonomic
level of your relative abundance plot
right so in the interactive
visualization plot the taxonomic level
is fixed once we have uh when we are
running the pipeline or when we are
accessing the pipeline setting up the
pipeline here you can change that from
the family level you can change that to
phylum
level and
explore their informative uh
level of informativeness right
look at this the phylum level is not
very informative because it is most of
them are actually populated by
and
the best level at which we can study
this is at the genus or family level
genus could be too varied
and it can have several of the
not applicable
are unknown uh resources
in them for example unc unknown or
uncultured organisms or other organisms
here as grouped by these purple cases
right they are all other which are
unclassified genus so
one level
related to
a syndrome or not from the disease that
is the host disease
yes
and then it is going to update by itself
and then you can explore for them for
their
separation for their
distribution so again in the diversity
plot you can check uh different
categories of different uh annotations
of your of your samples here i'm focused
i am focused on death syndrome you can
also change this up by selecting for
example body mouse index body mass index
etcetera etcetera that we want to select
so uh this dashboard gives you uh
freedom and flexibility to change the
annotation to change the grouping level
and to change the um
display of the uh of the associated
plots that uh
um that are not possible in the um
in the interactive platform or data that
are very helpful when you are opting for
when when we want to understand uh meta
genomic data analysis using a code free
option
and this can also be performed using r
as a
[Music]
tool for analysis and that is actually
given in the in this project 13 which is
uh
which explores the role of high fat diet
and obesity using model system like
mouse right and when we go back to my uh
keynote let's see
can you see my screen
so it's loading it's not visible yet
yes
yes and now it's just yeah right the
user helpful
the
advantage of using a model system to
understand microbial the effect of
microbial community and their abundance
level on several different
aspects is actually that we can use
specific antibiotics to completely
reduce or completely nullify the
existing bacterial load in the model
system which is not possible for human
samples so we can take a mouse model for
example and then completely devoid that
most model for for any
trace of microbial community in their
cut and then load them up with
specific
we can
process at the end of uh
observation process and quantify their
abundance level that is what is actually
done in this specific project so they
take the mouse samples and for
completely cleaned up mouse they give
the mouse
microbial community that is developed or
that is built or that is actually
developed for different mouse that takes
hypha diet and for another mouse
microbial
samples from micro samples from another
mouse that take normal diet so and the
behavioral changes for mouse that
received microbial transplantation
community transplantation from high fat
diet fed mouse and um compared to the
microbial
transplantation transplanted mouse that
received
transplantation from a normal diet mouse
and their behavior this
differences are actually studied after
given number of time and that are
actually
explored in this specific
project so
on
this downstream analysis which takes the
tables or which takes
the abundance table which takes the
taxonomic table under which also takes a
sample
uh sample annotation and then we can
perform downstream analysis using r and
using a package that we will definitely
explore during the program that
and their usage in using philosophy
practice right in this final sig package
we can we can bundle up this abundance
table and this uh
this taxonomic information and this
annotation information into one object
and this one object is what has been
repeatedly being used to study for
example
to measure the diversity across
different sample or across groups of
samples in terms of alpha diversity or
in terms of beta diversity that can also
be
studied
right uh yeah this is uh this is simply
the um
nmds plot to show their differences uh
using bray distance method and some more
phylogeny based distance methods like
unifrac and
these ones are also explored and given
ah
detailed account of how to perform this
analysis using r as a tool for
performing this analysis this gives you
a lot of flexibility in terms of the
number of samples to analyze in terms of
what are the distance methods that you
can choose to
analyze and
visualization options like pcoa nmds are
you a umap to use to visualize your
samples so um and it also gives you a
lot of freedom in in terms of grouping
of samples according to phyla kingdom
and etc or you can also for example um
restrict your analysis to top 25 otus
top 50 depending upon their abundance
levels or depending upon their diversity
levels in this case so that can also be
studied so
this
rsa tool for downstream analysis gives
you all the codes for performing this
analysis and it also gives you a portion
where you can try your knowledge of uh
performing this analysis from the
previous two resources right it gives
you or this console is a is a is an r
console that is loaded at the back end
and we can perform all the analysis
given in these measures of diversity are
given in these sections um
i use these to perform the analysis and
we have given you
small
assignments and challenges and these
challenges can be accessed from lesson
six this is a continuation of lesson six
so we go back to lesson six quickly
which focuses on how to set up these
downstream analysis in pilosic
environment
down down
yes in try it yourself section
so we give options or we give
links to the input table and then we
actually
leave out some of the key portions of
the syntax for example here this is left
out free or left out incomplete so that
you can refer or you can base on your
understanding of how this is performed
complete this analysis in this console
and gain uh
good feedback about for your own
understanding uh
[Music]
for this code based lessons so
similar analysis is also perform is also
possible in python and more details are
actually available in
other associated resources and also in
we will explore python's option to
perform this analysis in the program
also so with that i will actually
conclude my uh
portion of this webinar and if you have
any queries until now please put this up
in the put this put it in the chat or
we will address it and if not i will
want to pass this on to spurs i believe
thank you so much
uh let me share my screen and i'll
quickly guide you through the program
curriculum the fee structure and the
resources
you will avail when you get enrolled
yourself for the program
[Music]
so could you please confirm if you can
see my screen and i
am audible properly
yes pressure audible but there seems to
be like a background disturbance a
little bit
okay okay give me a moment
uh now is it uh fine triggering yes yes
thank you so much
so um
okay let me just start
so uh this is the program page of meta
genomics data analysis and as you can
see that the program is going to
commence from next week thursday that is
22nd of september
now if i'll scroll down you can see a
program overview which will tell you
why this particular program is designed
what all uh
things and aspects we'll be covering in
this program about like for example
operational taxonomic units then
functional bacterial community uh there
are two pipelines kind pipelines etc
and further if if you scroll down you
can see an interactive session where
there are few dates highlighted so which
means that the uh on these particular
dates the session will be conducted
either asynchronous or live sessions
would be there so that would be
uh like we will uh mailing you out about
each session
on the right hand side you can see the
curriculum of the program
the topics for each session
that is for example the first session
that is on 22nd it is on introduction to
meta genomics where we will be covering
the 16s meta genomic sequencing
then introduction to ngs for meta
genomic sequencing overview of the tools
and resources for this program and then
there are some associated online
resources per session when you scroll
down you can see the second session
title the topics we'll be covering and
then again the associated online
resources
and same goes on
for the third session
after the third session there will be an
in-depth hands-on project example which
will be on american gut and human
microbiome variability and the topics
which we'll be covering is related to
gut brain access microbiome and behavior
use of small subunit 16s rna for
identification of microorganism
metagenomics data to chow versus hft etc
and then there are few associated online
resources
so here you can see the
comprehensive curriculum which we have
developed for this meta genomic data
analysis program
if you'll scroll down further you can
see three different tenures for which
you can enroll for
the three different tenures are one is
of 45 days 60 days and then 90 days the
common resources which are there which
is applicable for all three ten years
are online tutorials project examples
coding sessions session recordings
online mentor support via our skype
groups or telegram groups online
technical support uh
then certificate after completion of the
program and example cloud pipelines on t
by input server
so these are some of the common
resources which you will get away now
what's the difference between the three
results uh 10 years so in 45 days
you will be going through with an
extensive training
right
in 60 days you have an opportunity
with the extensive training you can work
on your research proposal and present it
to our mentor for evaluation and
feedback
and other than that you have an
opportunity of one-on-one mentor
sessions
in 90 days you have an opportunity to
work on an independent research project
with extensive training and again
one-on-one mentor sessions are there so
the outcome for 60 days uh program would
be poster presentation in omics research
symposium or any other international
conference
and the outcome for the 90 days tenure
is the research publication in a good
peer review journal
so this was a brief about the uh program
resources
the fee structure okay so now you can
see here the fee
here uh you can see like on the right
top
right top corner there is a flag and a
drop down menu
if you click on that you can see there
are different currencies according to
different country or location so
according to your location you can
choose your currency
for now right now i i'll be opting for
usd in dollars
so the fee for 45 days is dollar 150 for
60 days it's dollar 300 and for 90 days
it's dollar 450 and obviously we are
giving scholarships to those who are
like uh those are those are in financial
aid or something
so
we will be
giving scholarships so you can mail us
at marketing at the rate omixlogic.com
so i'll be just
writing the mail id here in the chat box
and you can email us
for further queries or scholarships so
this was a brief about the curriculum
the structure
program structure the fee structure and
the resources
now i could see that there is a quite
this there is a quiet discussion going
in going on in the chat box regarding
team and the hackathon and
so i'll quickly uh
navigate you or walk you through the
landing page of the hackathon so we are
really very excited to launch our
hackathon that is on the microbiome in
health and wellness and
so this hackathon like it will bring
together innovative ideas from
biotechnology and the intersection of
genomics business and computer science
so here the students the researchers
across the globe will like they have an
opportunity to broaden broaden their
horizons
by meeting different people meeting
experts from
commercial commercial experts or
academic experts or research experts
and uh having their valuable feedback
and
brainstorming with them etc so we'll be
in like we'll be
in some duration we'll be rolling out
mails and we'll be
publishing on our social media platforms
on linkedin uh
then instagram or facebook or twitter
about this hackathon
so the theme of the hackathon revolves
around
it looks like the screen is not shared
for the hackathon page
okay okay i'm okay so i'll just stop
sharing my screen and i'll share it
again
just a moment
okay so uh
now is it visible
yes it is okay okay
so uh as i was saying that uh we are
quite excited to launch a hackathon that
is that the title of the uh hackathon is
on microbiome and health health and
wellness
soon we'll be rolling out some mails and
publishing on our social media handles
about the hackathon how you can register
further for the hackathon
so uh the
hackathon like the hackathon will get
start from uh like comments from
november 1 and it will end on november
28th so the three weeks like from
november 1 till november 22 there will
be some workshops going on for weekly
basis and uh the categories for those
workshop will be
developing cutting-edge technologies it
will include omics and microbiome
metagenomic sequencing then uh talks
related to bioinformatics recommendation
etc
week two workshop will be related to
human microbiome dieting supplement
where we including uh
talks related to gut migration
microbiome health indicts skin
microbiome beauty comfort and aging and
also vaginal microbiome pregnancy and
femtech and the third week will be
devoted to computer science and machine
learning
where we'll be learning about the
infrastructure for computational
analysis tool methods and algorithm data
visualization and experience user
experience
so um
talking about the team costing
this particular hackathon like students
can participate in group group of three
minimum three or maximum five
right and you can make group either like
your colleagues or your peers from same
university or maybe from same industry
or you can even connect via linkedin as
i could see
uh one of the participant was asking for
like who is like interested in
teaming up with her
so uh that's like that's a great idea by
this you can
broaden your horizon and uh
spread more roots into different network
and networking people etc
so now uh the costing for individual
student is dollar hundred
if you'll come in a group then it's
dollar three hundred per go a group
three to five students and uh we have
some special discounts for our partner
university so it is dollar hundred per
group which include three student in the
group
so this was a brief about the hackathon
and the registration
everything we'll be disclosing soon
so you will be
getting mails you will be seeing social
post on our
social media handles
so through if further you have any query
related to hackathon or related to the
registration part of the metagenomics
data analysis program please feel free
to put your queries in the chat box and
i'll be here to answer
thank you
uh suspect there is one query that is
can all these links and email be mailed
to our registered emails
uh yes uh definitely so uh
once uh like uh this
we'll be mailing you out the session
recordings as well as all these links
like the program page link which i just
showed you related to meta genomic data
analysis and the hackathon page link as
well to your registered email address
uh then we have another query that is
please share the recorded version of the
webinar or training i missed part of it
yeah sure so uh we'll be rolling out uh
the recorded version of this webinar uh
tomorrow
and uh please do check your promotional
and spam folders because sometimes uh
mails land up in